You guys, this is crazy, but scientists have
created a whole new kind of matter- Yeah,
time crystals are here!
Hey there time bandits, it’s Trace for DNews.
Physicists have created a new form of matter
called TIME CRYSTALS!
No, it’s not the time crystals you may have
seen on Rick and Morty.
These time crystals have properties we haven’t
seen in other matter.
Usually, matter is motionless at its resting
state and only has potential energy until
kinetic energy is introduced to it.
For example, a ball at rest is chock-full
of ‘potential energy’, and when it’s
kicked, that energy is converted to ‘kinetic
energy’, the energy of motion.
But time crystals actually move at their ‘resting
state’ or their ‘ground state’ — that’s
when atoms have the lowest amount of energy.
They’re like a ball that is forever in motion.
In other words, they are always unstable,
down to the atomic level.
They are the first non-equilibrium matter
ever created!
Regular crystals are an arrangement of atoms
in repeated three dimensional patterns, called
a lattice.
The patterns are duplicated through space,
whereas time crystals duplicate their patterns
through space AND time.
They are essentially 4 dimensional crystals!
The concept of time crystals was first theorized
by Nobel Prize winner Frank Wilczek in 2012.
He surmised that there could be hypothetical
matter that could move periodically even while
in a ‘ground state’.
In theory, the time crystals could move without
the application of energy because they would
be designed to be inherently unstable, breaking
the symmetry of time, resulting in atoms that
are in perpetual motion.
Once the theory of time crystals was out in
the ether, researchers focused on coming up
with methods to create this new matter that
could break time symmetry.
A blueprint was created and posted online
in August 2016.
The author called his paper, quote, "the bridge
between the theoretical idea and the experimental
implementation".
Two teams, one from University of Maryland
and one from Harvard, took the basic ‘blueprint’
of how to make time crystals and got to work.
Both teams were successful but used different
methods to achieve the same results.
The University of Maryland created their time
crystals with a line of 10 ytterbium (it-er-be-um)
ions.
Within these ions, the spins of their electrons
were entangled.
The researchers’ goal was to interrupt the
ions’ normal equilibrium.
To do this, they used two lasers, one to flip
the ions and a second laser to create a magnetic
field.
The first laser flipped ions over, causing
them to interact with other ions, making them
flip over, all within the magnetic field created
by the second laser.
This process continued until all the ions
were oscillating, or spinning.
This was considered normal behavior for a
regular crystal, but researchers noticed something
strange.
As the lasers continued to nudge the ions,
they realized that the ions were now reacting
more frequently than they were being nudged.
According to researcher Norman Yao, this is
like jiggling jello and having it move when
you weren’t poking it.
Researchers had essentially broke the time
symmetry and created a new form of non-equilibrium
matter that continued moving at its ‘ground
state’!
Voila!
A time crystal!
Researchers at Harvard went about creating
their time crystal differently.
Instead of ytterbium ions, they used nitrogen
vacancy centers, which are certain impurities
found in diamonds.
And instead of using lasers, Harvard researchers
used microwaves to cause the ions in the diamonds
to flip and oscillate.
Different method, same result: time crystals.
This new form of matter could lead to future
breakthroughs in quantum computing and understanding
the various forms matter can ultimately take.
Researchers have also remarked that their
creation of time crystals is evidence that
time symmetry can be broken and that non-equilibrium
matter CAN exist.
If you want to know more about quantum computing,
check out Crystal’s video on quantum computers
here!
Let us know down in the comments what you
think about time crystals, if they blow your
mind a little bit, make sure you subscribe
for more DNews and thanks for watching.